- How do stay driven?
I'm gonna ask you a question,
how don't you stay driven?
Let me get this right.
You won the lotto of
the universe which is
you are a
human being on Earth.
You, I'm just gonna say this and
I don't think people think about
this, you won the lotto.
You, in the universe,
you're not some
weird specimen in Mars
that does nothing.
You're not a bird.
You know, you're
not a sunflower.
You are a human being on Earth.
You won the
ultimate, ultimate lottery
and you're not driven
and you're not fired up and
you're not going for it and
you're willing to sit like a
lump and just wait to you die.
You suck.
Like, I don't know, you suck.
How I stay driven?
Because I couldn't even
comprehend the alternative.